mit dem russischen Überfall auf die
Ukraine ist der wichtigste Brücken
Energieträger für die deutsche
Energiewende weggefallen und es fehlt
uns jetzt eine neue Strategie Strategie
bedeutet nicht nur zu sagen wo man in 20
Jahren sein will sondern auch wie man
dorthin kommt das hat die
Bundesregierung bislang immer noch nicht
beantwortet stattdessen handelt Sie sich
von einem Entlastungspaket zum nächsten
typischerweise zu breit angelegt klar
ist nur die Energiepreise werden kaum
noch auf das vor krisen-niveau
zurückfallen damit es aber auch unklar
welche Unternehmen in Deutschland noch
eine Zukunft haben und das Risiko ist
groß dass man mit all diesen
überbrückungsprogrammen Brücken ins
Nichts baut weil man gar nicht weiß wo
das andere
Ufer liegt Energie ist knapp und wir
müssen jetzt Energie sparen und es geht
jetzt um die intelligentesten Umgang wie
wir das hinbekommen nun da müssen wir
die Welt nicht neu erfinden der beste
Mechanismus um mit Knappheiten klar zu
kommen sind Märkte und
regelsignale die können uns am ehesten
sagen wo wir jetzt insbesondere auf Gas
verzichten müssen Preise sind eben nicht
nur Symptom des Problems sondern immer
auch schon Teil der Lösung das
Preissystem ist das Navigationssystem
der Wirtschaft man würde beim Auto das
Navi auch nicht abschalten nur weil der
Weg ruppiger wird die Bundesregierung
war auch zunächst auf der richtigen Spur
nämlich mit der gasumlage zu versuchen
diesen Anstieg der Preise möglichst
breit wirken zu lassen so dass jeder es
spürt und nicht nur diejenigen die das
Pech hatten dass der Gasvertrag gerade
auslief oder der eigene Lieferant
insolvent gegangen ist davon ist sie
leider wieder abgerückt hat sich dann
zunehmend auf die Diskussion um eine
gaspreisbremse eingelassen und damit
versucht die Preissignale eher wieder
runter zu dimmen das ist aber der
falsche Weg wir haben einen hohen
Importanteil das bedeutet das bedarf
erheblicher Subventionen die
preiseingriffe viel zu sehr in der
Breite das erhöht die Inflationsgefahr
und da wir jetzt immer mehr nationale
Alleingänge in der EU in diese Richtung
erleben drohen wir sogar damit die
Weltmarktpreise für Gas hochzuhalten und
damit nicht die europäischen Verbraucher
zu entlasten sondern die
Lieferanten in Übersee zu füttern kurzum
die gasumlage war besser als ihr Ruf man
hätte sie noch verbessern können aber
sie war insgesamt der richtige Weg und
die gaspreisbremse hält nicht was sie
verspricht das heißt wir sollten wieder
auf einen Kurs zurückkehren wo wir viel
mehr mit den Marktkräften spielen als
permanent gegen sie hier natürlich
direkt die Frage an den
bildpolitikgeschäft kann es denn
überhaupt sein dass man noch mal
zurückkehrt zur Gas im Lager nein ich
glaube der Weg ist ausgeschlossen also
da gab es viel viel Kritik und die
gasumlage ist ja de facto auch schon
abgeschafft also das wird nichts mehr
werden am Ende sind wir bei einem Punkt
den wir gerade eben ja auch schon
Sprachen
hat das angesprochen und sie jetzt
gerade auch noch mal am Ende die Frage
wie hilft man denjenigen die es am
nötigsten haben in dieser Krise
eigentlich am stärksten ich weiß nicht
ob die gasumlage da das beste Mittel
gewesen wäre klar ist glaube ich dass es
darum geht vor allem jeden Haushalten
und auch dann jeden Firmen zu helfen die
am härtesten betroffen sind die sich das
am wenigsten leisten können die
möglicherweise auch vom Konkurs dann
stehen und viele andere Menschen können
das eher abschöpfen aus dem eigenen aus
eigenen ersparnisten aus dem eigenen
Einkommen und müssen das auch tun dann
klar ist auch der Staat und das sind am
Ende wir alle immer wir können das ja
nicht selbst alles bezahlen es können
viele für einige bezahlen aber nicht
alle für alle das wird nicht
funktionieren ich würde an einer Stelle
Ihnen widersprechen Herrgott nämlich was
die Umlage betrifft da ging es ja darum
dass die großen Energiehändler also wie
Juniper war immer das Beispiel jetzt
hohe Einkaufspreise haben aber
langfristige Verträge mit den
Stadtwerken oder auch einzelnen
Großkunden kommt ins entsprechend die
höheren Preise nicht weitergeben kann
warum wir das über eine Umlage machen
sollen und nicht gleich in dem wir dann
den gefährdeten Unternehmen helfen in
dem was jetzt hinterher auch passiert
ist und aus meiner Sicht zurecht und gut
passiert ist also diese Schleife die man
gedreht hat die dann dazu geführt hat
dass Trittbrettfahrer auftauchen die das
gar nicht nötig haben die hätte man
vermeiden können also ich würde sagen
sie müssen eigentlich ihr Argumenten
schärfen ohne dass ich dazu habe in ihre
Argumente zu schärfen aber zu sagen
direkt Hilfen jedes Mal direkt Hilfe was
die großen Energiehändler betrifft und
direkt Hilfe was die direkten ja was den
ärmeren Teil der Bevölkerung über der
hartz-iv-schwelle die ohnehin Wohngeld
und
die die Miete und die Energie bezahlt
bekommen auch hier direkt bezahlen dann
ist es kein Eingriff in den
Preismechanismus und erfüllt völlig das
Ziel dass sie sehr dankbar für die Frage
weil er genau auf den Punkt zielt an dem
die Debatte falsch abgebogen ist nämlich
der Eindruck ist entstanden wir hätten
diese gasumlage nur um die Unternehmen
zu retten darum ging es ja gar nicht das
war ein Nebeneffekt sondern es ging
darum die höheren Beschaffungspreise
also die je höhere Knappheit die sich
jetzt an den Märkten gezeigt hat
möglichst auch bei den Preisen der
Verbraucher auch ankommen zu lassen dass
also jemand der das Glück hatte
vielleicht noch einen langlaufenden
Vertrag zu sehr günstigen Konditionen zu
haben dass auch der das Preissignal
bekommt nein Gas ist jetzt knapper
geworden also bitte nicht so viel
gasverbrauchen wie in der Vergangenheit
das war die primäre Zielrichtung also
hier die preisüberwälzung zu
beschleunigen das ist nicht optimal
ausgestaltet worden durch mit diesen 2,4
Cent für jeden das hätten wir noch ein
bisschen besser machen können aber die
Richtung war schon genau die in die man
hätte gehen können und das ist kein
Eingriff in dem Sinne in das
Preissystem sondern man hätte hier die
die Star der Preise gelockert und daran
hätte man Zwischenfrage stellen wenn man
das zur Preise sind ja unfassbar viele
Begriffe ich frage mich gerade wirklich
ob die im Bundestag das überhaupt alles
verstehen es ist ja hochkomplex und man
hat ja das Gefühl die verstehen es gar
nicht wenn man auf die Steigung Preise
schaut das würde ich jetzt so das glaube
ich nicht sondern es gibt genügend
Überblick das ja also es gibt ja auch
ein also auch gerade den Ministerien in
den Fachabteilungen sehr gute Leute das
ist glaube ich kein Erkenntnisproblem
ist eine Frage ob man es politisch
tatsächlich mehrheitsfähig machen kann
daran ist man gescheitert denn die Idee
der Gasanlage ist ja nicht zufällig
entstanden und natürlich das ist jetzt
kein Instrument um die Bedürftigen zu
entlasten sondern das belastet natürlich
erstmal das muss man dann immer
flankieren mit entsprechend zum Beispiel
Energiepreis Geld war gar keine so
schlechte Idee dass man also einen
Betrag überweist und er wird dann
abgeschmolzen wir haben es mit der
Steuer gemacht ich kann mir das noch
aggressiver vorstellen dass man sagt
bist du mittleren Einkommen wird denn
dieser Transferbetrag abgeschmolzen
auch hier dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht
unnötig viel zusätzliche Kaufkraft in
den privaten Sektor Pumpen den das
aktuelle inflationsproblem ist leider
nicht nur ein Energiepreis Phänomen
sondern wir sehen auch dass die
heimischen Komponenten der Teuerung
bereits anziehen und zwar kräftig
anziehen viel stärker als es mit dem
stabilitätsziel der Geldpolitik
vereinbar ist und das ist eine ja auch
Nachfolge dessen was wir während der
corona-pandemie gemacht haben das wäre
also so oder so eingetreten dass jetzt
noch akzentuiert durch die Preise aber
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir hier die
Inflation nicht noch weiter anfeuern
denn das ist ja ein Bärendienst für
diejenigen die ganz unten in der
einkommens-skala rangieren für die wird
dann die Lebenshaltung auch teurer und
deshalb müssen wir gerade dafür sorgen
dass wir die sozialen Hilfen so gut
fokussieren die irgendwie möglich und
die Inflation beschäftigt ja uns alle
und auch wir bleiben hier bei 8:15 Uhr
weiter bei dem Thema